i think very often companies can risk
becoming reactive to things that happen
in the marketplace
which may so here's a great example
right let's use a real life example
blackberry was a really fantastic
company
who built a really fantastic product
with a really clear sense of vision
which is we make
strong secure extremely reliable
products and if you remember if you ever
had a blackberry
you could throw that thing across the
room drop it on the street and it just
didn't break
it just kept working it was the most
reliable product on the marketplace
you could type on the full qwerty
keyboard without even looking down you
could send a whole
email and governments and big businesses
loved it because it was
really secure and really reliable then
the iphone showed up
and the iphone was the new shiny object
and blackberry
instead of sticking to their core and
their beliefs
became distracted by the shiny
popularity of the iphone which is a
completely different
animal serving a completely different
audience
and they started trying to copy iphone
so they started putting apps on their on
their blackberries which what did it do
made it slow and sluggish
then they started coming out with flat
screens you're not going to make a
better iphone than an iphone
and they basically destroyed their
company because they completely went off
the reservation and
and abandoned their fantastic cause
there could be two marketplaces
where you have the shiny object of the
iphone that we use in our personal lives
and our companies prefer that we use a a
blackberry because it's reliable
it's safe and it's and it's really
really strong
and we could have had two dominant
players for two dominant reasons like a
pc and a mac
two dominant players for two dominant
reasons for do two different reasons
but they didn't they got distracted and
i can imagine that their that their
business people were saying you know
business is moving at light speed we
have to react
or we can work to advance our cause in a
different way and not become distracted
and that's part of the hard thing
which is are we stuck in our old ways or
are we actually sticking to our
sticking to our long-term vision that's
that's part of the difficulty of
business to know the difference